to CBS this morning from the Smithsonian
National Museum of the African American
history and culture his role in it so my
that was one year ago Wow Charlie we had
the honor of being the first media
outlet to broadcast from the newest
smithsonian museum since then nearly
three million have visited the National
Museum of African American history and
culture that was a good day right I was
something we're very proud of you there
it has become one of the most popular
Smithsonian destinations in Washington
Jan Crawford spoke with the museum's
director to reflect on the first year
she's outside the iconic building along
the National Mall Jan good morning well
good morning Charlie so you know more
than 8,000 people walk through these
doors every day that's more than twice
the number every day that visit that
organizers actually expected I mean it
has been an overwhelming response to a
place that really confronts these
painful issues that people don't really
want to talk about and celebrates the
triumphs nearly one year ago a ringing
bell signaled the museum's official
opening it is an act of patriotism to
understand where we've been with
presidents from both parties this museum
tells the truth and luminaries from
politics and entertainment historian
Lonnie brush laid out his hopes for the
new museum he helped create I realize
it's a clarion call to remember I have
to be honest two weeks before opening
that's terrifying was it more that you
know I built it now are they going to
come or how will they react well it was
more was I right to focus on slavery and
to give people a real understanding of
that was it right to start with the
slave trade and eventually get up to the
promised land of music or film then I
realized my wife said it's too late now
the museum was generations in the making
more than a dozen failed votes in
Congress over funding and then
controversy over where to build it
people don't like to talk about race in
this country well I think it's been
difficult because it really was about
race
and it was saying we're going to have to
open the veil if we do this Museum and
talk about a lot of things that we don't
normally discuss in just the last year
bunch has been forced to discuss the
departure of the country's first black
president violent clashes with white
supremacist nationwide arguments over
civil war monuments when you think about
where we are now compared to where we
were two years ago or two weeks before
this museum opened right I mean the one
thing you knew is that change was the
key to understanding American life right
and that nothing was linear race is
always going to be part of the great
divide how do we help people find
reconciliation healing over the Great
Divide and then go forward and go
forward the response has been
overwhelming
with free time tickets disappearing as
soon as they become available and crowds
waiting for hours to see the museums
more than 3,000 exhibits people are
coming in spending five and six hours on
average 70% of the items came from
people's homes the most powerful often
the most humble like freed slave Joseph
trammels 10 wallet and made to protect
his freedom papers misses to me what is
so moving about people trusting the
museum to be able to take those amazing
documents and those artifacts in essence
because of that we've been able to
create a sacred space the museum has
recorded thousands of visitors sharing
their reactions to the often emotional
exhibits I lived through that period I
am so happy today that things have
changed and relate them to today our
children are still very much at risk
through it all punches message is one of
hope when you're a historian of black
America you have to be optimistic the
enslaved people on whose shoulders I
stand who didn't get the chances I get
because of them America is a different
place and I believe very strongly that
we continue to make America a better
place and this museum is at the center
of that absolutely there was no doubt
that this museum
has a political agenda to make America
better now bunch told us that what
really has struck him most in this first
year is how people kind of view their
visits here it's a pilgrimage and in
fact museum staff have special trainee
to help people deal with all the
emotions that they feel when they walk
through the museum and tissues are
provided Gail
you need tissues we remember that day
very well and don't you think Charlie
you need at least a day to go through it
have you been yet bianna I have not and
it's out of my list put it on your list
to do it is the most popular a Museum of
the Smithsonian family people can't get
in it's free it's a perfect example of
why museums are so important exactly
train around the world and the
magnificent sense of how people rose up
and contributed things yeah to make it
what it is including Oprah making a huge
financial Cosmo glad we did that piece
Jan thank you